and mitch keller finishing up his
warm-up tosses and back
in the big leagues after spending some
time in the miners
jankowski hitting 311 with a home run
seven runs batted in
and he shoots this one the opposite way
that's a fair fair ball and hits off the
half wall and kicks back toward the
infield
and jankowski will be at second base
with a one-out double
there we go two outs
gets him on the 3-2 and it's a big k for
keller
well here's jt real muto
and jt lines it into left field to base
it rounding third heading for home as
jankowski the throw by gammel
is not in time jt coming through an rbi
single and the phillies take a
one-nothing lead
it's kyle gibson making his phillies
debut just acquired
the last day of the trade deadline
and the 1-2 pitch and a high fly ball
out to center field
playable for jankowski
[Applause]
that one hit back toward the middle
right at gregorius who fields it on a
hop
and the side is retired that was quick
that's a roller past the second baseman
defoe into
right field a base hit they have to
figure out what's going on with dd
gregorius and dede has to figure it out
too
balls hit sharply there's a base hit to
right center field bowm's on his way to
third he'll get there
first and third with nobody out here in
the second
hard-hit pick by nickowski throw to the
plate and they're gonna get the man
between second and third
quick tag and better yet they don't move
up an extra 90.
and the ball is bunted and now they've
got a chance for two
oh but dagowski throws to
third gets the lead man there and that's
out number two
and runners at first and second and it's
up to gene seguro
segura lines it out to right it's in the
gap it's going to take a one hop off the
wall
one run is in gibson's being way tall
lumbering home
he will score it's a two run double the
ball squirts away
and it's three nothing fillings
and a strike three call on the inside
corner
first k for gibson
castro a grounder to shortstop
love it another quick hit
harper lines it the opposite way that's
going to be in for base hit and it's
going to go to the wall
and gamble will play it off the 325 sign
bryce pulls into second
his 22nd double of the year
this time gets the breaking ball over
and now castro
well done and harper what was he doing
go figure first base runner the pitcher
mitch keller
two-and-one on gamel and a ground ball
and there's the first hit for pittsburgh
and mitch keller gonna head to third
see if more defeat can't collect a hit
here and get the bucks on the board now
and defo with a base hit gets the bucks
on the board
big two out two strike hit for defoe
now fly ball to deep center field that
wind and the leap and the catch by
brian reynolds and
a tip of the helmet respecting the play
the all-star center fielder just made on
him
even the man who hit the ball has to
appreciate and respect it
harper the other way again going back on
it is gamel
gamble to the wall it's off the wall he
did not play that
well and harper will get to second base
and he has his second double
so here's j.t romuto
and jt rips it down the left field line
that's an extra base hit going to the
corner and the phillies will get another
run
it'll be the second rbi of the day for
real muto he brings home harper
back-to-back doubles for the fills it's
a 4-1 game
code ponce
and there is the third strikeout of the
day and it's number 1000
for kyle gibson in his big league career
that's against marcus strowman line
drive caught by a diving gene segura
what a play
wow gamble's looking like are you
serious and gene
a little bit of a smirk on his face
cody ponce relieves mitch keller
there's a bloop out to center and bowman
has two hits today
his batting average continues to tick up
2-1 is lined out toward right that's a
fair ball going to the corner
balm on his way to throw and it's going
to be a ground rule double it kicked
over that small wall
double skies one out towards center it's
pretty well hit reynolds going back
it'll be deep enough to score boom
but also give gregorius a chance to go
to third
sacrifice fly for o'double herrera and
it's now a 5-1
game a two run double back in the second
and that's a high fly ball out to left
center field gambles on the rod he's not
going to get there it's off the base of
the wall
gregorius scores going to second is
segora he's there
rbi double his second two base hit of
the day
he looks out at reynolds in the center
and says you can't catch that one
and it's now a 6-1 ball game
as bryce gets his third knock of the day
so harper's gonna be aboard he's trying
for two
and he is safe at second
[Applause]
left side oh oh oh bryce
[Applause]
it's an infield hit for real muto well
runners at second and third it's
dede gregorius coming up he's two for
three
two two is line out to center field and
that'll drop in for a base hit one run
scores here comes jt heading for home
the throw to the plate he
is safe
broken background ball up the third base
line ponce
throws off balance not in time though
double is
there as nagowski has to come off the
bag
and i can't believe the bat made it into
the stands in this day and age
everybody's okay though we got a thumbs
up
sword right field and that's fair
and there's his first major league hit
hoy park
doubles at pnc park
[Applause]
puts a charge into one sending jankowski
back toward the trap
and he did he make the catch he did
and racing back toward first base and
safe there
that's it for kyle gibson he did a heck
of a job today 113
pitches in six and two thirds five hits
well they're going to let him go with
the bases loaded
there's a ground ball to left field a
base hit one is in here comes jankowski
he's heading home he'll score without a
throw
that's four rbis for real muto today
and the phillies lead it 10-2
[Applause]
inside ball four that forces in a run
and the phillies keep adding on they
have one hit in this sitting and they've
scored three
runs
line drive out to center field reynolds
is there makes the catch
tagging from third and heading home is
jt he'll score
herrera sac fly infield hit ground ball
base it to center field rounding third
heading for home is brad miller he'll
score
and o'duble has an rbi single his second
rbi of the day
and this has turned into a trouncing
it's 13-2 and it is john nagowski
well obviously there's a lot of
ballparks that i didn't play in oh but
you know what i mean there's a fly ball
out to right off the scoreboard for real
muto
marchand is on his way to third and jt
pulls into second base
another double for the phillies that's
the fourth of the day
miller walked and scored his last time
ground ball
out to second he'll get an rbi run
scores
out towards second that'll get a run
home
balm's retired but he picks up another
rbi 4-3 on the put out
jt crosses the plate